my Chi I noticed the clock is ticking on
Kurt cousins in the Washington Redskins
and what happens if they don't get a
long-term deal done what is the time
frame for this and what happens if they
don't get a long-term deal done well the
deadline dance for p.m. Eastern Monday
the 17th of July after that cousins will
be and remain he's already under
contract for 2017 no long term deal can
be negotiated until after the regular
season ends and then after the regular
season Washington would have a window of
exclusive negotiating rights with
cousins but the reality is next year it
gets even more expensive it would either
be 34 million plus under the franchise
tag for a third year 28 million plus
under the transition tag which would
still let cousins go out and try to find
someone to son into an offer sheet
Washington would have a right to match
it with no compensation if they choose
not to or hit the open market and how
often have we seen a healthy franchise
quarterback hit the open market it
typically doesn't have them have two of
them next year because Drew Brees even
though he's gonna be 39 franchise
quarterback the way things are set up in
New Orleans he could be headed for the
open market cousin could be headed for
the open market but if this thing
doesn't get done by Monday at 4:00
that's the scenario next year and it's
one of the reasons why Cousins agent is
driving such a hard bargain Cousins
holds all the cards in this one and
every bet that's been placed so far has
worked out in his favor how would you
describe this relationship between
cousins and the Redskins well I mean
it's strange Dan they used the franchise
tag on him twice but they don't want to
pay him like a franchise quarterback it
more specifically they don't want to pay
him in accordance with what his
circumstances would dictate right they
could have gotten him for a much cheaper
deal during the 2015 season once they
realized that he's the guy and Robert
Griffin the third isn't then after the
season end and they apply the franchise
tag they didn't want to pay him a
contract based on what 19.95 million
cash in hand for 2016 would have
dictated it's a very easy formula once
you know what a guys franchise tag
salary is so they wait a year they use
the tag again it all gets more expensive
this year because they're starting a
23.94 million for 2017
next year it gets even more expense I
mean at some point they just have to
they screwed up they have to admit that
this is the guy we want over the long
haul and they have to pay him in
accordance with his specific
circumstances every quarterback is
different and Washington has not three
three straight times now been willing to
pay Cousins in accordance with what his
circumstances would suggest and we'll
find out by next Monday whether or not
they change their mind and do it now
well this also comes to mind if I'm Kirk
Cousins do I want to be with an
organization that's not smart enough to
understand that I am their franchise
quarterback well you know last week
Jason Campbell was quoted as saying that
during his time as the Washington
starter there was a whole lot of crazy
going on and Cousins has been privy to
whatever Crazy's been going on in
Washington and if you don't feel wanted
don't want to feel wanted and
appreciated in our jobs and yeah I mean
hey he's getting paid 23 million this
year I mean that's a whole lot of we
want this guy but they haven't made that
long-term commitment leadership so
important for quarterbacks how hard is
it for cousins Polito locker room when
he's on a year-to-year arrangement and
that and the team hasn't given him that
long-term deal and damned if this plays
out and he had sealed the market a lot
of people assume he makes a beeline for
San Francisco and Kyle Shanahan but what
about Shawn McVeigh in the Rams what if
Shawn McVeigh decides the Jared Goff
isn't the guy the guy that Shawn McVeigh
inherited when he took that job
I mean mcveigh's a head coach to the
Rams because of Kirk Cousins to a
certain extent and so what if McVeigh
and Shanahan get into a tug of war next
year in the same division four cousins
agree fascinating the way this plays out
if Washington doesn't do the deal by
Monday and most people right now think
that Washington isn't going to have the
epiphany they need to have to pay
cousins the money that his circumstances
suggest he should get what's the lady on
bail situation with the Steelers I mean
not at a contract right so he skipped
the off season program he's got a 12
point 1 million dollar franchise salary
for 2017 which is well above the running
back market right now LeSean McCoy is
the highest-paid running back on a
multi-year deal at 8 million dollars
so here's bail at 12.1 so how do you
negotiate a long-term deal well for a
franchise player
you take the 12.1 cash in hand you
multiply it by 1.2 to reflect the 20%
raise for what he would get next year
under the tag
that's the starting point so it's like
25 million over two years for Le'Veon
Bell well who's going to give that kind
of a money to a running back especially
the history of injury and a history of
substance abuse suspensions so I think
the Steelers are content to go just for
this year and then make a decision next
year what they're going to do with belt
but you know until belt signs his
franchise tender he's not under contract
he could hold out a training camp he
could skip the preseason he could show
up like four days before the start of
the regular season and still get the 12
point 1 million and are the Steelers
comfortable with that with their running
back being not a part of the team at all
until right before the start of the
regular season
if Bell does that he has the power to do
it under the franchise tag and the
Steelers have the power to rescind it
and you know I'm not saying they're
going to do it but you have to at least
keep an eye on the possibility that the
Steelers get on the brink of the regular
season if Bell doesn't show up let's say
they're happy with James Conner the
rookie from Pitt they're happy with the
other guys they have we're all making a
hell of a lot less than 12.1 million
this year they could rescind that tender
and throw Bell out into the open market
and no one's gonna pay him twelve
million dollars in late August early
September when they already had their
teams ready to go talking to Mike Florio
from Pro Football Talk let me circle
back to what you were talking about with
Drew Brees that he's not going to have
this is it this might might be it in New
Orleans is that the the distinct
possibility that and it doesn't seem
like Brees is slowing down so is Drew
Brees gonna play elsewhere next year you
know he always says he's committed to
the Saints for what happened last year
he was entering the final year of his
contract he did a one-year deal one-year
extension and then he has said he's not
going to do another extension this
contract is going to expire and there's
a term in there that they can't use the
franchise tag regardless of whether they
would or wouldn't he's gonna hit the
open market unless he and the Saints
work out a new deal by next March when
the league year begins and I think he
you know he he I think in some level
look I think he means a lot to New
Orleans and New Orleans means a lot to
him but at some level he wants to sit
back and have control over what happens
next year over what happens over the
final years of his career I mean what a
shot you know every year there's a rumor
Sean Payton's gonna leave the Saints
what if this is the year that Sean
Payton finally leaves that's going to be
a factor for Drew Brees especially if
Sean Payton once Drew Brees to be his
quarterback wherever Sean Payton may
and up so you know breeze is in a
situation where he's going to call the
shots on this one and yet he'll be 39 in
January but you know we marvel all the
time at Tom Brady as he gets close to
the 40 that he hasn't lost anything well
Brees hasn't lost anything either how's
this going over with NFL players these
contracts that we're seeing certainly
with the NBA the amount of money you
know the whole guaranteed contracts
thing that players have complained about
for decades you know can you see this
being brought up next go-round
well here's the thing next go-round if
the players want to have more money
individually they need more money
collectively Dan and the way to get more
money collectively is to get a better
deal and at some point to get the best
deal that you can get through labor
negotiations you have to be willing to
press the nuclear button like the owners
did six years ago when they lock the
players out and we're ready to lock them
out into the regular season the players
though aren't regarded as being willing
to miss game checks they aren't being
regarded as willing to miss football
games and what are they going to do
without revenue so the strike option
seemed to fizzle and die in 1987 when
the strike failed that year and actually
ended up getting a much better
collective bargaining agreement through
the court system after that so you know
we're back at the point where if they
want to get paid more money they're
gonna need to be willing to walk away
and the question is are they willing to
and we're talking about 2021 Dan guys
who are going to be making the decision
we're not they're going to strike most
of merchants still in college and some
over in high school so who knows how
this is going to go but but you know and
the thing I'm guaranteed contracts if
the NFL adopted fully guaranteed
contracts right now I guarantee you that
99.9% of all contracts would be two or
three years maximum because teams
wouldn't want to commit guaranteed money
beyond that and that would be good for
the players too hey we'll go right back
to the market in two or three years
instead of being stuck on the back end
of a contract that's more favorable to
the team than me but that would be the
practical outcome we would have guys
changing teams a lot more often than
they already are
I see what you did you guaranteed be
guaranteed contract things so I don't
know I make no guarantees I don't lie
I've learned
what's that that Twitter account old
tapes exposed III no longer take a hard
line on anything all right no
predictions well I promise it okay but
I'm gonna ask you I'm gonna leave you
with this you can you can have dak
Prescott or Carson winds going forward
between the two between the two I would
probably lean Carson West because I
think he did more with a lot less last
year
then what Prescott did with with the
best offensive line in football and his
EQ Eliot and a defense it was a lot
better last year than it's going to be
this year what if dak Prescott was
taking number two overall in Carson wins
when the fourth round oh wow thought of
it that way
I that would probably influenced me to
say that Prescott I'll be honest with
you not that I'm ever dishonest with you
how they teach you that in law school
don't say to be honest with you because
that implies that you're otherwise not
honest I'll be candid with you and say
that would be a factor for me because
somebody thought enough of him to make
in the second overall pick in the draft
do they teach you how to lie in law
school
no they teach you how to tell the truth
persuasively they don't teach you how to
lie what they teach you how to do dance
more important than anything other that
they teach you and this has served me
well in this business they teach you how
to spot when someone is lying to you all
right give me a couple of tells I mean I
mean apart from you know inconsistencies
logical inconsistencies and the thing
people say I mean the all time tell is
baby I learned this from Seinfeld the
touch of the face and the higher you
touch on the face the bigger the lie and
it actually it's true when I'm
interviewing people and they go to the
face when they Scranton area when they
scratch their head when you scratch the
head scratch the nose scratch the cheek
anytime there's a pause and you go to
the face it's it's a lie guaranteed no
guarantee that one I'm gonna keep an eye
on my guys in here
just make sure okay here's the thing
what a strange coincidence if you
actually have an itch on your face and
and it's not you know it's not just to
tell your face actually itches because
you know you got a skin condition let me
try this right now I'm like Paulie were
there things that were sent
the mancave addressed to me and there
somehow in your possession at home oh
you just put your hand to your face two
hands both hands hey Mike thanks for
joining us enjoy your time off alright
hi Mike Florio the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience